good morning Hank it's Thursday January
4th I'm standing on top of little Pisgah
mountain in North Carolina that was
actually recorded on Wednesday January
3rd but you'd have no way of knowing
I believe that's what they call movie
magic Hank in your last video you asked
me to continue our discussion of our
differences I think one of the most
important differences between us is that
you are excellent at living in a way
that's commensurate with your values
whereas I not for instance I didn't
recycle until I watched Inconvenient
Truth but I'm still sort of if he on it
and also I didn't vote in 2000
even though I could have voted in
Florida Oh George Bush it's all my fault
I'm so stupid let's change the subject
also we have vastly different happy
dances well I noticed that in your last
video you completely ignored my eat five
sheets of toilet paper while discussing
the political situation in Nepal
challenge let's just admit that that was
some awesome pronunciation and if you're
not going to eat five sheets of toilet
paper while discussing the political
situation in Nepal well I'm going to all
right green you better do this in one
tape because it's not gonna be fun oh
well hum about the political situation
in Nepal and so there are these malice
rebel who could hold more than half of
the country who has Maoist rebels
anymore oh no I can't do it Hank I think
this stuff is two-ply too I think that
was part of the problem because you get
the 1pi stuff I can just
just down that but this stuff move oh
and by the way I have great news
Brotherhood 2.0 viewer Peter just had a
baby well actually his wife had the baby
she was in the neighbor for 32 hours I'm
thinking maybe we should get them a baby
present what do you what'd he call baby
president baby warming present baby
shower baby baby a baby present I was
thinking maybe we could let Peter pick a
project or challenge for us what do you
think